und wir sprechen über einen fall der
immer mysteriöser wird es hat sich hat
zu tun mit einem hubschrauberabsturz
fragezeichen in baden württemberg es
geht um den deutschen gründer wolfgang
haupt vorletztes wochenende hat sich das
abgespielt in baden württemberg der ist
er mit seinem helikopter über einem wald
eben in baden württemberg abgestürzt
dabei ums leben
gekommen aber war das ganze ein
tragischer unfall hier sehen wir noch
mal die bilder von der absturzstelle
dort in baden württemberg oder war es
ein attentat möglicherweise inzwischen
gibt es hinweise darauf der focus
berichtet aktuell über solche hinweise
auf ein attentat auf den deutschen
gründer wolfgang haub der dieses
umstrittene unternehmen orgasmus
intelligence geführt hat gegründet hat
er habe so heißt es laut focus das hat
die familie offenbar bekannt gegeben vor
seinem tod morddrohungen erhalten und
dann eben dieser absturz von dem sie
hier noch einmal bilder sehen dort aus
dem wald in baden württemberg der
inzwischen ein bisschen nach attentat
riecht stellten jetzt in unserer bild
reporterin janine wollbrett sie ist vor
ort an der absturzstelle janine was für
eine mysteriöse geschichte hilft uns ein
bisschen licht ins dunkel zu bekommen
was genau könnte dort passiert sein und
wie gehen die behörden jetzt vor ja in
der tat ist es ja mysteriöser fall
bestehen jetzt hier auch direkt vor der
absperrung hier kam krachte der
helikopter am 17 10 runter um 13 uhr es
gibt aussagen von angehören bewohnern
hier in der nähe von buchen die auch
einen knall gehört haben wollen und als
heute morgen habe ich mit der
zuständigen staatsanwaltschaft
gesprochen in mosbach das sagte mir auch
der erste staatsanwalt florian sommer
das jetzt ja auch hinweisen nachgegangen
wird das ist sich vermutlich auch um
attentat handeln könnte mehr wollte er
dazu aber nicht sagen
das heißt in diesem fall ginge es
tatsächlich um mord ermittlungen
möglicherweise in diesem fall wolfgang
haupt sag uns ein bisschen was du weisst
über ihn weil es dieser mann der da in
diesem helikopter am vorletzten
wochenende um leben gekommen ist er hat
eine it firma auf der gesichtserkennung
und es wurde auch gesagt dass er schon
vor mehreren wochen drogen telefonisch
von einem anruf bekommen haben soll mit
arabischer stimme was genau
dahintersteckt ist allerdings noch
unklar die ermittlungen stehen dazu laut
staatsanwaltschaft noch ganz am anfang
denn in vielen herzlichen dank für deine
einschätzungen zu diesem mysteriösen
fall danke dir